back to the pandemic which has hit
crisis levels in america's heartland
one hospital in topeka kansas has had to
turn its
waiting room into a hospital room for
those without cobit because the
er is just too full our lead national
correspondent that's david begno's in
fargo north dakota
david good morning to you that state we
we're told just hit another daily high
and covades the numbers tell the story
here
gail it is so bad the dakotas both north
and south lead the world they lead the
world right now
on a per capita basis when it comes to
the number of people who are dying
on a daily basis and look politics has
affected so much of what's happening
here
i mean people will fight you on the
facts and if you were to ask hey how's
north dakota handling the pandemic
watch if you were grading it
it would be an f probably an f minus
it's that bad
joel heitkamp hosts the number one talk
radio program in north dakota
the former democratic state senator
takes tons of calls about kovid
every day in a largely republican state
and you have a right to call into this
show anytime you want well the height of
hypocrisy in north dakota right now is
how we
care uh for our elderly if you go into
costco you go into walmart you go into
any of these places
they say put your blank mask on uh
you're gonna put it on
but you know what they're not willing to
do that around grandpa and grandma after
they've been out in the bar
and i can't figure it out just yesterday
north dakota reported 37
new covid related deaths that is a new
high
they have the second highest mortality
rate in the world
and some of their hospitals are
overwhelmed that's why the u.s air force
has sent
60 nurses to help staff hospitals around
the state
in south dakota the debate over wearing
a mask continues
statewide i think if we choose to wear
it for our own protection
that's on us but to force us to wear it
you know
like i just i'm against that around 50
percent of south dakotans say they do
not wear a mask
kelby krabenhoff ceo of sanford health
the largest health system in the dakotas
suddenly retired last night after
creating a firestorm this week
by saying he wasn't going to wear his
mask at work because he had recovered
from the coronavirus and was immune
now in a statement his own health system
said they had mutually agreed to part
ways and that his views didn't reflect
those of the company
he also downplayed the seriousness of
the pandemic
to our sioux falls cbs affiliate kello
land it's hard for me to say we are at a
crisis
that would be misleading from a clinical
standpoint
he is not a doctor but his chief medical
officer allison suttle is
i asked her would you classify what is
happening here in the dakotas
as a crisis i would 36 hours after she
contradicted her ceo
on cbs this morning he is gone
dr suttle is also calling on south
dakota's republican governor christie
nome
to mandate masks statewide but the
governor refuses to
north dakota's republican governor doug
burgum did that
two weeks ago how much is trump's
messaging affecting
local politics here in north dakota it
affects everything
here in north dakota if he tells a lot
of these folks
that the science doesn't back it up or
that you can shove a light bulb up your
keister and it's all going to make
things better some people here are going
to believe it
and he hears from people every day on
his radio show let me tell you one quick
story
yankton south dakota small town in the
southern part of the state the
commission met to talk about mass
mandates
and they decided no the local newspaper
said the commission
wants more time to educate people here's
a reasonable question we're eight months
into a pandemic
how much more time do you need how much
more time do you need to educate people
about it
no exactly david thank you and please
please don't shove a light bulb up your
keister and you said that with a
straight face i was thinking that too
but you do have to say that anthony
because people are paying attention in
different ways yes they are